let me ask a ridiculous question
when you zoom out when a human
civilization has destroyed itself and
alien graduate students are studying it
like three four five centuries from now
what do you think we'll remember about
this period period in history the 20th
century the 21st century
this this time we had a couple wars
we had a charismatic black president in
the united states
with um a couple pandemics
what do you think will actually stand
the the
stand out in history no doubt the
uh rapid technological innovation
of the last 20 to 30 years uh how we
created a whole
virtual universe we didn't have before
and of course that's going to go in
directions you and i can't imagine 50
years from now
but this will be seen as that origin
moment that when we went from
playing below the rim to playing above
the rim right to be
all in person to having a whole virtual
world and in a strange way the pandemic
was a provocation to move even further
in that direction and we're never going
back right
we're we're going to restore some of the
things we were doing before the pandemic
but we're never going to go back to that
world we were in before where every
meeting you had to fly
to that place to be in the room with the
people so this whole virtual world and
the virtual personas
and the avatars and all of that um i
think that's that's going to be
a big part of how people remember our
time also the sort of biotechnology
element of it which
which the vaccines are part of um it's
amazing how quickly this is the great
triumph how quickly
we've produced and distributed these
vaccines and of course their problems
with who's taking them but
but the reality is i mean this is light
speed
compared to what it would have been like
not just in 1918 in 1980
yeah one of the and sorry if i'm
interrupting but one of the
disappointing things about this
particular time
is because vaccines like a lot of things
got
politicized used as little pawns in the
game of politics
that we don't get the chance to step
back fully at least
uh and celebrate the the brilliance of
the human species that's right
this is yes there are scientists who use
their authority
improperly that have an ego
that um when they're
within institutions are dishonest with
the public
because they don't trust the
intelligence of the public they are not
authentic and transparent
all the same things you could say about
humans in any positions of power
anywhere okay that doesn't mean science
isn't incredible
and um the vaccines i mean i don't i
don't often talk about it
because it's so political and it it it's
heartbreaking
to it's heartbreaking how all the good
stuff is getting politicized yeah that's
right and it shouldn't be
it'll seem less political um in the long
arc of history
it'll see it'll it'll be seen as an
outstanding
accomplishment and as a you know a step
toward whatever maybe they're doing
vaccines or something that replaces the
vaccine in 10 seconds you know at that
point right
yeah it'll be seen as a step those will
be some of the positives i think one of
the negatives they will point to will be
our inability at least at this moment to
manage our environment better how we're
destroying our living space
and not doing enough even though we have
the capabilities to do more to preserve
or at least
allow a sustainable living space i'm
confident because i'm an optimist
that we will get through this and we
will be better at sustaining our
environment in future decades
and so in terms of environmental policy
they'll see this
moment as a dark age or the beginnings
of a better age maybe as a renaissance
or maybe uh as a as the last time
most people lived on earth when a couple
centuries afterwards were all dissipated
throughout the
the the solar system and the galaxy very
possible if
the local resident hometown resident mr
elon musk has anything uh to do with it
i i do i do tend to think you're
absolutely right with all this political
bickering
we shouldn't forget that what this age
will be remembered by is
the is the incredible levels of
innovation yes i do
i do think the biotech stuff worries me
more than anything
because it feels like there's a lot of
weapons that could be yet to be
developed
in that space but i tend to believe that
i'm excited about by two avenues one is
artificial intelligence
the kind of um the kind of systems we'll
create in this digital space that you
mentioned we're moving to
and then the other of course this could
be the product of the cold war but i'm
super excited by space exploration sure
there's a magic tour to humans being sp
and we're getting back to it i mean
we were enthralled with it in the 50s
and 60s when it was a cold war
competition and then after the 70s we
sort of gave up on it
and thanks to elon musk and others we're
coming back to this issue and and i
think
there's so much to be gained from the
power of exploration
you